sur le campus de cancérologie de
toulouse ces chercheurs se consacre tout
coronavirus le test de dépistage qu'ils
viennent de mettre au point pourrait
changer la donne le principe innovant
c'est surtout donc l'utilisation de la
carte
ft à qui est une carte utilisée par la
police scientifique et qui permet en
fait de recueillir la salive c'est un
prélèvement salivaire
et à partir du moment où la personne va
déposer une goutte de salive une simple
goutte de salive sur cette carte déjà
danger biologique sera inactivé deux
avantages la sécurité et la rapidité du
procédé
le prélèvement est réalisé à domicile le
patient n'a pas à sortir de chez lui il
reçoit le quitte et le renvoi sous
enveloppe retour l'analyse est réalisé
dans les 24 heures et les résultats
peuvent être connues en 48 à 72 heures
maximum
l'analyse pcr se fait par prélèvement
nasal nous explique la paix c'est en
fait une technique qui relativement
sensible de par en fait les différents
contaminants qui pourrait venir vous
contaminer nos différences
d'échantillons et ainsi faussé les
résultats surtout une fois isolé les
échantillons sont analysés par cet
appareil puis numériser le résultat
négatif ou positif est envoyé par mail
ce test présente un inconvénient majeur
il n'est pas remboursé par la sécurité
sociale pour obtenir l'homologation du
gouvernement il doit d'abord être
utilisé pour des milliers de personnes
impossible faute de moyens pour cette
petite start-up ces chercheurs espèrent
collaborer avec un laboratoire plus
important dans les semaines à venir